Thank you very much, Shirley.
This is a very proud
and a very happy moment.
And the winner is Linda Hunt.
[APPLAUSE]
This is extraordinary.
There was an Indonesian phrase
in the film, which translates
into English as,
"water from the moon"
and it means that
which is unattainable,
the impossible, that which
one can never have or know.
Making The Year of
Living Dangerously for me
was "water from the moon."
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
And the winner is Marlee Matlin.
I am --
I just want to thank
a lot of people.
To tell you the truth, I
didn't prepare for this speech.
But I definitely want to thank
the Academy and its members.
And I want to thank my mother
and father, Eric, Marc, Gloria,
Zachary, and Liz.
They're here tonight with me.
And I just want to
thank all of you.
I love you.
[APPLAUSE]
Ladies and gentlemen,
Christopher Reeve.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
What you probably
don't know is that I
left New York last
September, and I just
arrived here this morning.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
And I'm glad I did
because I wouldn't
have missed this kind of
welcome for the world.
Thank you.
When I was a kid, my friends
and I went to the movies just
for fun.
But then we saw Kubrick's,
Dr. Strangelove.
It started us thinking about the
madness of nuclear destruction.
Stanley Kramer's,
The Defiant Ones
taught us about race relations.
And we began to
realize that films
could deal with social issues.
Now when you look at
films like Platoon,
and Philadelphia, Lorenzo's Oil,
you realize the power of film
to present painful but
important issues to the public.
So here are just a
few more of the motion
pictures that have courageously
put social issues ahead
of box office success.
They've enlightened us,
they've challenged us,
and they've given us the
opportunity to learn.
Hollywood needs to do more.
Let's continue to take risks.
Let's tackle the
issues in many ways.
In many ways our film
community can do it better
than anyone else.
There is no challenge,
artistic or otherwise,
that we can't meet.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Ladies and gentlemen, here are
Seth Rogen and Michael J. Fox.
[JAZZY MUSIC]
[APPLAUSE]
I'm going to pretend
half that applause
is for me even though I
know deep down it is not.
Some of it was for you.
You think like, 30%
of it was for me?
Some of it was for you.
Great.
Either way I'm at the
Oscars with Michael J. Fox,
a DeLorean, while
wearing future shoes.
All I have to do is sing
"The Schuyler Sisters"
song from Hamilton in
front of the world,
and I will have completed
my entire bucket list.
(SINGING) Look
around, look around
at how lucky we are
to be alive right now!
Angelica!
Eliza!
And Peggy!
Look around, look around --
OK we can't do the whole thing.
OK, fine.
I don't want to be in
the room when it happens.
OK.
Let's keep going.
We're here to present
the award for Achievement
in Film Editing.
Since we're talking about
influences and influencers,
I want to mention how much
we all owe to editors.
There isn't a
nominee here tonight
that doesn't depend on editors
to show off their best work.
Here are the nominees for
Achievement in Film Editing.
[APPLAUSE]
Short films allow for new
voices to be seen and heard
without the constraints
of budget or permission.
I've seen these films
and they are beautiful.
And if you haven't
seen it, come see it.
[APPLAUSE]
Here are the nominees for
Best Live Action Short Film.
The Oscar goes to
The Neighbors' Window.
[APPLAUSE]